[Music]
Thank you very much,
great greeting, How are you,
Victoria Fest? Hey, it's wonderful to be
here with you. I'm super
impressed with this event with all the
people I've met. Wonderful women, real
entrepreneurs, the triumph
of the feminine is felt here, so
it's really.  an honor to be here
Sharing with you So Well
thank you very much for having me thanks
to Ana Victoria thanks to the Victoria Fest
and Well today I would like to share a
vision a Cosmo vision of the future of
our perception of our
imagination
of our
existential anxieties and possibilities  What
we have ahead of us
I would like to start with a saying from the
philosopher Edward or Wilson. He says that
we have
paleolithic brains, we have
medieval laws, and we have
technologies of gods,
and there is the dissonance between these
dominant paleolithic brains full of ego, trying to
survive at all costs. Okay, these are.
obsolete medieval laws and these
technological capabilities that give us the power of
God.
Now you are
entrepreneurs. You understand that to
transform the world we are going to have to
apply ourselves, we are going to have to apply
our capacity to innovate and we are going to
have to use our
technological instruments.  to overcome but we
also need to expand
experience we also need more
wisdom more empathy When it to
expend and then use or God like
Technology to dress the Grand challenge
of humanity therefore Today I am going to
share with you a vision of the future of
technology but also a vision  of the
future of Mental Health and the future of
consciousness and the imagination of the human being
so let's begin for me all this
begins with a passion for
creativity
this all begins with a passion for the
imagination of the human being
our ability to imagine and then
create  What we imagine then
materializes in the world. Therefore,
this Passion for creativity and
imagination has become for me
a passion for technology. The reason is
that I see technology as our
creativity concretized in the world. I
see  technology as our second
skin I see technology as an
extension of our imagination
cognitive philosophers David Chommers
and Andy Clark in their famous essay the
thesis of the extended mind talk about how
today in this modern world the
human being is what is our  creativity
what is our brain what is our
mind is distributed between biology
and technology
literally our
cognitive structure is a hybrid of our
brain and the instruments
we use To extend our
visions in the world as the
philosopher Marshall says we first create  the
instruments we create the tools we
create the technologies but then
those technologies those tools
create us it is a circular relationship
it is a co-evolution and it has always been like this
if you travel through time you travel
one hundred thousand years into the past when the
first being  human explored the
surface of the African savannas and
picked up for the first time, let's say, a
stick on the ground and used it to
reach a fruit that was hanging
from a branch. We have used the
instruments, even the simplest ones,
to extend what
we achieved.  do to overcome our
limitations and extend our
capabilities therefore this
coevolution between our innovation and
how the instruments and technologies
that we create create our environment is what has
allowed us the ability to accelerate this
very rapid coevolution
and that acceleration has been exponential
now today in  Today we live
in a world defined by change we
live in a world where disruption
has become part of the normal a world
of permanent acceleration a world where
there is almost an existential vertigo we
do not know where we stand we
sometimes feel lost  we feel
anxious change is the new normal
The question is
why exactly today these
changes these disruptions that I
imagine you feel as
entrepreneurs why it
is happening at this speed Because
if you look at all the ways
that the  human beings have innovated during
our history, we have had many
innovations that have transformed the
world. In other words, since we learned to or
developed writing or controlled
electricity for the first time,
we used fire to cook, each
of those innovations gave a
new definition to what we mean.  It's being a
human being, then you add the internet,
Aviation, whatever the point is, there have
been several points, several lines in the
sand, several lines in the sand where when you
crossed that line everything was different,
so it's nothing new that things
change, no.  It is nothing new that we
are transformed through
our innovations it is part of
our evolution however in the
past these innovations were accumulated
over several generations so
the typical person perhaps saw a
transformation in their life if that
Generations today is different
Nowadays you graduate from university and
what you studied has already become obsolete, that
is, today the changes are
happening in real time, therefore
another type of mind is needed, another type
of consciousness, we first of all have to
understand the trends.
What And here comes the very
important concept as entrepreneurs who
must understand it, which is the concept of
exponential technological changes.
Human beings think about change in a
linear way. Our intuitions about
change are linear. It is what
we assume is our instinct. However,
today  Nowadays, progress and innovation
accelerate exponentially. So it
takes us by surprise every time there is a
dissonance between our intuitions and
the reality of the world in which we live,
therefore the first thing to
do is understand on an intuitive level
what change or change means.
Exponential progress for this the best example
is used by the futurist Gray
today he is the head of engineering at
Google
he uses the example of the 30 steps This
sounds technical but it is very easy it
will immediately click in your
brain The example  of the thirty
steps works like this If you take 30 linear steps
when you reach step 30 you progressed 30
steps that is linear change you take 30
linear steps you reach 30 That is the
intuition of the human being now If you
take 30 steps exponentially you
reach  billion steps Ok
understand that 30 linear steps takes you
30 30 exponential steps takes you to a
billion not a hundred not a thousand not a million
billion
that level of Progress is the reason that your
smartphone your Smartphone
your iPhone Whatever phone you have Okay
It is a million times cheaper, a
million times smaller and a thousand times
more powerful than a supercomputer
that 60 or 40 years ago was worth 60
million dollars and you needed
special privileges to access it. Ok,
the mobile phone that people are using
today.  who are recording this
talk and they are
Times smaller and Thousand Times
that that supercomputer that was worth 60
million dollars 40 years ago that
tells you everything you need to know about
exponential progress and digital progress
what they call digital transformation
And as they say  in the Wall Street journal
software is eating the world so
everything is becoming an
information technology
and
therefore everything is going to start progressing at
these exponential levels at these
exponential speeds so
assume this  At an intuitive level,
the space of possibilities in
which you explore will change. When you innovate, when you
create, when you plan, you already have
different schemes.
The writer Steven Johnson, in his book
Where New Ideas Come From,
A History of Innovation, talks
about what he calls the  space of the
perimeters of possibility
and he describes it as a shadow of the
future that falls on the present and
offers us a map of all the ways that
the present can be reinvented
Explorer
Now I would say to you by understanding
now you begin to explore  those
perimeters of possibility on
exponential scales these trends continue
in 25 years that same level of Progress
is going to convert the mobile phone that
you use today to plan your
meetings and write your ideas is going to
disappear it is going to go inside our
body it is going to go  inside our
ears or what is coming are Brain
Machine interfaces it is interfaces between
the brain and technology it is going to be an
extension we are going to become a
super organism where we all
connect with everyone and who knows what they
can do with something like that Now the
Technology has always been and always
will be a double-edged sword. You can
use writing to write
poetry and educate the masses. But you can
use writing for propaganda
to share hatred. In other words, fire can
cook or it can burn enemies.
technology any
instrument that extends our
capabilities It is a tool a
double-edged sword therefore This
is where the idea of ​​consciousness comes in
empathy our ability to
direct
these powers of gods that we have every
day more towards the future in which
we want  Living now, for me, sharing
this vision has become a
life project. I started making
short films, that is, two to three
minute videos shared on the networks
more than a decade ago. These have had more
than 500 million views, something
that would never have happened to me.  imagined without
any marketing team simply
sharing something that infects people
as a vision of possibility because
that's where it starts to expand the mind we
have to expand the intuition about
what is possible
our Comfort zone Because all the
good all the growth all
transformation all evolution exists
Beyond our Comfort Zone
I would then like to share some of
these videos, the first one I am going to
show you is called to be human is to be
trends human and it is a celebration of the
human capacity to overcome first
video by  please
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
[Music]
now the idea behind these
short films is to make you feel like
you are watching a propaganda for a
Hollywood movie, that is, I said
How  share ideas about what the human being
has inside what we are
possible what what what what is not
possible for us How to transmit
How to communicate this power of gods that
we have, as I told you at the beginning,
we have these paleolithic brains, the
laws  medieval those
medieval institutions But these capacities to
innovate that give us this power of God and
to extend a little more that
metaphor that is not a metaphor I am going to
share a little more about these
exponential trends I have had a
decade traveling the world
sharing this  to companies like Cisco
Microsoft Intel IBM etc.
many people raised their hand to me and
said Ok Jason these changes the
digital transformation I understand we all
see it at work in Industries
etc. But in the end we are
biological human beings living in a
concrete world  In other words, that does not change
exponentially. Maybe
computers Yes, but for us, no good,
as I said before, software is
eating the world, everyone is
becoming a
computer technology, everything is being
revealed as software, for example,
biology.
You may think about your health,
but  Nowadays medicine is something
reactive, you get sick and then you go and get
checked, but the ability today to
understand biology as
true software, what they call mastering the
information,
has revealed that in the end we are
alphabetic until the end,
it is a code, our genes.  They are
software programs and our
ability to modify those
software programs Is moving three times
faster than these
exponential trends The next world that is going to
be Is going to be transformed by
disruption the industry that is going to be
transformed like never before in the same
way  that the digital world
has been transformed Now the world of health is going to change
Ok, what they call
today There are already medicals, those are
instruments the size of a mobile cell phone
that can diagnose you better
than ten doctors, they call it a laboratory
inside a chef
or  editing our genes with technologies
that will allow us to cure ourselves of
genetic diseases or reprogram the
immune system with emmary nate
Technology, for example, giving
software instructions to your body
to eliminate your cancer tumors,
there is a reason that in founders like
Larry page the founders  from Google
are now entering the Bio Life
sciences
And that is also progressing at
exponential levels, therefore
if we are interested in
transforming ourselves,
evolving ourselves,
now we are going to have instruments that are going to
allow what they call self-
termination in a way that we
cannot even imagine.  As the
streaming says in the very Future generation,
a new generation of artists and
poets are going to write to us the way
Shakespeare did in
jeans How that transformed Whatever
extends the human I share this Not
necessarily so that you found
your own entrepreneurial company in
biotech alone  so that they start to think
that this is not just a metaphor, the idea
that we have to transform ourselves
is literal
we going Where we heading What do We
want to turn ours into and to show you
that the next video is called the future
a bus please
[  Music]
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
Ok breathe, you
are also with me still
okay I spoke to you at the beginning I am going
to repeat it again this idea that
we have these technologies of gods an
exponential future everything is changing
we feel a little  lost a little bit
anxious so in principle I want to
change How you Percy with coming so
that you start thinking
exponentially because what this means
is an exponential opportunity to
solve the problems of human beings
so right now I would like to talk a
little about the problems  of the
human being at the level of Mental Health
According to
this, it is another passion of mine By the way,
Mental Health according to the
organization today with all this
Progress with all this capacity with
all this wealth with everything we have
achieved Okay we communicate with
cell phones we fly  in planes in the
sky we explore with telescopes in
space on the surface of other
planets with all that more human beings
today die by suicide than they
die by violent conflict and
natural emergencies earthquakes
storms Hurricanes etc.
disaster
try to imagine that, that is, people
say  I can't take it anymore I can't take it anymore I don't want to take it anymore I don't want to
live there is nothing that will get me out
of this depression there is nothing that will get me out
of this trauma that I have
inside I am suffering and I want to
die
imagine that we
are talking about a
Mental Health pandemic  of mental crisis of
existential crisis now the human being
that is animal storytelling we
live in our narratives
the world makes sense only through
our narrative our identity is
sustained by a narrative
Where I'm going what I'm doing It's
are Stories We  are so stained by are
Stories
a mental crisis begins when the
narrative that is sustained no longer supports you
When The Story that You tell yourself
about yourself is no longer
as they say, the human being can live
several weeks on food several days without
water But not even one  hour be careful
If yourself Story If your natutu you
enter a hole from which you cannot
wake up and from there comes the crisis in
which we live today
we do not have enough narratives that
unite us in comment
Why former Vice President Obama was
so effective in his  rhetoric because he
had what Martin Luther King also
had which is called Soho Force
the force of the Sun of the soul The force of the
soul
United in comments
What is the narrative well in principle
a narrative that I offer
you is that these
exponential changes that  sometimes they scare us you
can give it a refram and now This
exponential change means
exponential opportunity to overcome all the
challenges that felt impossible
Every limbing believe is now this in the
face
and Fui can make computers
[Music]
we have to repair where we are broken
The  The problem is that many of these
collapsed narratives come from trauma.
Trauma becomes a filter of
interpretation on your world. It becomes
like glasses that you wear and you
see through those lenses and you see with
those lenses but you don't see the lenses themselves
when  you plot when you stop
Everything you use the pressing
When you're ensus Everything you see
makes
anxiety this definition I loved it
is Temple this location
experience is now Over The terminal
in your World So how do we
get rid of those traumas How do we
reconstruct those narratives Well today
Nowadays there is a very exciting space
University
several other institutions are
making
like psychedelics
sacred plants like magic mushrooms from
Mexico or ayahuasca from Brazil and Peru
and other sacred medicines that have been
used by indigenous people
that you catch people
depression that don't  has responded to
traditional medicine and with two
therapists you give them an acision with two
with the Silvina asylum, for example, it
cures them of depression how it cures them
because the content of the experience
allows them to create a new narrative
where they understand themselves better where they
connect with the  humanity where
imagine that a religious experience
can wake you up and take you out of the
black hole of depression or anxiety
the inverse of the plot
actually Go and have On The man that is what is
coming and that is what
these studies and this next one are showing
video explores and in series Power plot on
highways next video please
[Music]
So as you can see we are here
for a
massive transformation the psychedelic industry
is exploding and these are also
exponential technologies that
can exponentially transform
our Minds So I see it as
an inside out and we see the technology
that we are creating there but also
the technologies that are
transforming us inside this The era of
cyberdelia of Cyber ​​dellick age where
cybernetics
digital transformations and
psychedelics as they enter into a
hybrid The era of  the cyberdelia of
Cyborg and What happens to the beginning
Ok you are Paleolithic Minds full of
ego and competition and domination and fear
these Paleolithic Minds are expanded
and transformed it means that around
those expanded and transformed Minds they
can modify these
medieval institutions and then they can use these
tools  of gods to paint a
world where all the challenges of the
human being are superimposed and in the end we
go to the stars so this
next video that I am going to show you
takes this concept that I call it the
read find the builder redefine the
billionaire saying that in  the era of
exponential changes where our
perceptions are transformed
wealth a billionaire is not measured
by dollars in the bank but a
billionaire is measured by the number of
people positively touched
thanks to these exponential trends
as you understand or were expend Mind
with God like technologies
that you can dream the possible
like us Wake the [ __ ] up next video
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] let them
breathe How are you cool cool
how can you see
this Vision
It's a narrative this is Story
destroyers
This is not guaranteed this depends on
you a  Of the things that give me the most
joy about this event, they told me that it is
90% women, that is,
my goodness, that is what
we need, that
is, the power of the feminine, more empathy, more
creativity, less violence, less
domination, everything that you bring,
all the intuition
I  It brings so much happiness to be here
Sharing with you
right here at this Victoria Fest event
with these wonderful women now
to finish we have talked a lot about
narratives I am a storyteller I
studied philosophy and cinema I love
movies I love cinema I love
storytelling  This is how I understand
This is how I learn This is how I
communicate one of the technologies that
excites me most today is Hey it the art
made with Artificial Intelligence I
imagine that you Guy Steve on the
internet true yes okay That today
Nowadays you can write some words,
give an instruction to the algorithm and it
creates something spectacular. Now there are
many people who say this is dangerous
because you no longer need any type of
talent to be an artist, but I think
that this is what is eliminating is the
space between being a child and being an
adult who was trained to be an
artist but children are also
artists what they don't have are the
tools. So I see this
Art technologies as an ability to
give us all the power to be like a
little child who can dream about Alice
in Wonderland and have it
created in real time as a
storytelling tool.
Artificial Intelligence is not Miriam
It's Language and Inspired by that she was
experimenting with making
visualizations using
Artificial Intelligence to
complement the  my narratives, that is,
what you are about to see
right now is a video that, unlike
all those that were edited in a
traditional way, you are going to see a video where
all the words that I am
communicating, the concepts are being
visualized by
Artificial Intelligence  around me The idea is
that you are inside my imagination
as it unfolds the narrative and
paints a vision of the world in
which we can live When you
literally
have imagination so it becomes and That's
Where I see your Evolution
destiny's no space
Imagine
Like this  the last video please and
then questions and answers
volume please
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music] [Music
] [Music] [
Music]
[Music]
[Music] [Music] [
Music] [
Music]
no
[Music]
the works the world you can Maker
Whatever you wish
First the world
like
[Music]
that the full
[Music  ]
floridas into the central
Well friends thank you very much dear thank you thank you
for your attention I
thank you fully
Oh no
Okay we have time for some
questions and answers I think yes
then raise your hand and I think
we bring you a microphone I think yes the
microphone is over there  and there is the
first question okay
ah hello hello how are you Thank you very much listen
two questions how do you get inspired to
create all these videos that would be the
first and the second what book would you
recommend for those of us who have
traditional companies and take advantage
of all these changes and  not to be left
behind of course those would be my
questions thank you thank you for your
question the first question is how do
I get inspired
No lie
Well the ironic thing is that obviously I talk
a lot about technologies and
innovation but I also work a lot
internally I working Myself I working
mindfulness meditation  nature, that is,
my mental health is part of my job,
one of the things that helps me a lot
are activities that take me out of my ego,
activities in which I can
disappear and when I say disappear
I say everything the little voice
oriented on what you want to do,
you want to achieve or  sea ​​default World the
conscience of everyday life has to
disappear
I really like any activity that
is immersive that is, for example I
really like free diving in the
cenotes of Tulum for example I get lost
in nature I talk with the
fish underwater  I disappear into
another world and being transported to another
world brings you back to this world
curated and ready to create and ready to
share
to inspire me
a book that I recommend a
wonderful one is called What does
technology want by Kevin Kelly the founder of
wire magazing What  technology
a brilliant person and he talks about
technology simply as something that
expands our possibilities and a
very inspiring narrative very optimistic
that you are not going to like it thank you
Well here Yes hello
again
Yes I already turned it on there he listens to me Ah super
Hello hello super  Interesting,
my question requires a little context,
speak a little harder, please.
Oh, you hear me,
so my question requires a little
context, so it's going to be a little
long
with all this you're telling us and
obviously not living under a
rock.
The ability that we have as individuals
to create stories and share them in
recent years has been
growing exponentially and
now with all this much more so
it is increasingly easier to make a podcast
Become a content creator that is to say
share stories
but I think that part of the  The value of
stories, in addition to telling them, is that
someone listens to them and that they move
someone, so we
still haven't reached the point where we
can live three hundred years, our
time is limited, and with so much
content created by so many people,
there are so many stories that rightly
can deserve recognition.  sorry to hear them
how do you see the future in which there is
this balance of people who create
stories who create content and people who
consume it excellent question and you are
right in the sense that when
everyone is publishing
no one is publishing it is not diluted  You
are right,
I have always had faith in the idea of ​​the
marketplace of ideas,
you know, in other words, in business,
everyone is trying to start a
business. But there are people who are more
successful and we are assuming that they expand and become
successful.
mainstream ways of getting forms and what you
my call the Monster business
and I have always thought that the same is true with
content. I mean,
I remember a study in the New York
Times that said that the content that
goes viral the most is the content that inspires
people to  sharing is content that
inspires two emotions, one anxiety and
fear and the other amazement,
obviously using fear so that
something is distributed is something that is used
a lot, the media uses it,
sometimes you get on tiktok and you say
Wow, that is,
and  since everyone wants tension there
was a very interesting article that
said that
tiktokping is like something planted by the
chinese because tiktok in China the
content is filtered there so that it is
educational in Unity
Science
here it Stupid video
you are what you consume you are what  What are
you exposing yourself to? I have
seen my content now I am
assuming that my content is good
maybe you say it is
crap however I have seen my
content being diluted The more and more and more
and more and more people  They start
making content They start making podcasts
and there is great content There is a lot of
content I say it's wonderful that there
is so much content Well but
there is also a lot of garbage and the truth is that it is
something that is
original There
is a lot of controversy there I like to
think something Bread  All of you today
selective
selection that
is to say the
internet
like You have to control your diet you
know that's why
obesity in the United States
has become such a big problem
[Music]
obviously I don't have the
right answer but thank you thank you
how are we on time
Okay many  thank you A hug thank you
thank you all the best
[Music]